A couple weeks ago I made a video called 19
Things You Missed in Truth or Dare (2018),
and at the end of that video I challenged
you, my subscribers, to give me some truths
and dares in the comments for me to do in
a video.
The time has come for me to make that video.
Welcome back everyone.
My name is CZ and this could get ugly real
fast.
So here are the rules.
I had you guys leave comments on my video,
and I told you that I wouldn’t do anything
illegal, anything that spends a bunch of my
own money and that I wouldn’t delete my
content.
I promised to do the top rated ones in a video,
so I’ll be doing 5 of the top rated truths
and 5 of the top rated dares, so let’s see
what you guys came up with.
“I dare you to dress like a cat for a whole
things you missed﻿”.
OK.
Next episode will be Things You Missed in
Sunny Family Cult on Saturday, so I’ll wear
the cat ears for that episode.
I’ll wear them in this video too.
I think they look pretty good on me if I must
say so myself.
This one has both a truth and a dare.
Truth: What is a guilty pleasure show/movie
that you like that not many people enjoyed?
I would say The Happening.
I think it was a really cool idea and a very
suspenseful movie.
It’s almost like The Birds, but with trees
instead of birds.
Plus, what other movie can make trees seem
scary?
I mean come on.
I’m guessing a lot of people didn’t like
it because you have two comedy actors in Mark
Wahlberg and Zooey Deschanel in much more
serious roles.
So maybe it’s not what people were expecting.
And I like movies where there’s horror going
on, but at its core, it’s a more relatable
story about human relationships.
OK and this guy’s dare: I dare you to put
on as many shirts and pants as possible within
a time frame of 2 and half minutes.
You have to put them on one over another and
they can be anything like a tank top or jacket.
OK what?
This is the weirdest dare I’ve ever heard.
Why is it so specific?
I mean why--?
This reminds me of a Weezer video that I've
seen, but I’m gonna do it and speed up the
footage, ok here we go.
Seven pants, ten shirts.
Try and beat that.
You know what, anyone who can beat that, film
it and put it on video, send it to me and
if you beat it I will put it on my channel.
That's how confident I am.
Alright, so the next one is a truth and it's
asking me: How did YouTube change your life?
Well, it's changed my life twice really.
When YouTube first came out I was not a creator
and more of a consumer.
And it was just amazing to see the shift from
traditional media to new media.
You had these videos coming up, an video would
go viral and everyone would be talking about
it.
It was just really exciting because there
was nothing like that at the time.
We had these creators for the first time.
There was Smosh and Lisa Nova, Kassem G, Daxflame...
The content that they were making was just
so much different than anything that you would
find on television or in the movies.
So it was really cool to see that and it just
changed the way I looked at media.
And then obviously it's changed my life again
more recently with me becoming a creator.
It's allowed me to make the videos that I
want to make and have my own career off of
it which is amazing and before YouTube there
was just nothing like that.
If it wasn't for YouTube and just online media
in general, I would probably be scraping through
footage for some studio somewhere; painting
out wires and doing tedious visual effects.
Oh and then one other thing I forgot to say.
Another thing that really changed my life
with YouTube is tutorials.
Tutorials are amazing.
You can learn how to do anything.
You don't have to go and take a class if you
want to learn something.
Even if you're just doing something around
the house like how to build furniture you
can just pull up a tutorial and see exactly
how to do it.
You can learn things that would have taken
years to learn before and you can just do
it immediately.
Alright, next dare: I dare you to play outlast
2 for 5 hours or 3 hours straight.
Alright.
Here we got.
Outlast 2.
I'm taking off these clothes first though.
So here I am playing Outlast 2 because you
guys told me to.
I've never played an Outlast game before,
and thanks to Orange Studios for helping me
set this up and lending me his capture card.
Blah, blah blah.
I'm gonna get demonetized for this video.
Lynn Langermann is an investigative journalist
seeking the answers behind a pregnant woman
murdered under impossible circumstances in
rural Arizona.
You are Blake Langermann, her husband, assistant,
and cameraman.
Oh sweet, I get to record stuff?
Neither of you are fighters; to navigate the
horrors waiting for you in the desert, your
only choices are to run, hide or die.
OK, so I had a little recording issue.
Basically none of that footage is gonna be
usable.
But I am about 3 hours into the game right
now so I figured I'd just play it.
So yeah, basically this guy, he's in the helicopter
with his wife.
The helicopter crashes.
The wife is lost.
He finds her eventually after looking around.
There're all these weird guys called heretics.
And you're trying to avoid them and it's this
whole spooky ordeal.
And eventually you find the wife but then
the heretics find you and the wife and weird
lady licks your face.
And they take the wife, basically.
So right now, what I'm trying to do is...
I just started this generator and I'm supposed
to go back and find this elevator.
So one of the creepiest parts in the game
happened just a second ago actually cause
you turn on the generator and someone hears
you.
See, these people are weird, dude.
Yeah.
You're in the generator room and this lady
just appears behind you and starts slashing.
I don't really know how to get by this lady
without getting slashed right now.
Do I run for it?
I didn't know how to run for the beginning
of the game either.
Alright, I made it.
See the camera gives you this magical night
vision which would totally work in a real
camera, and that's not sarcastic at all, that
lets you see better than your actual human
eye.
Oh man.
Oh...
When I see someone running around like that
it makes me nervous.
Alright.
Just gotta get a little bit further to get
to that elevator.
Uh oh.
Yeah so when you see one of those people,
usually not a good thing.
And when you hear a strange noise like that,
usually it means I should get the heck out
of here.
And I can't...
And I am gonna die.
Unless I can heal myself really fast with
the band-aid.
Oh wow, I just got stabbed through the stomach.
Wow.
Alright.
That was intense.
Rest in peace, me.
I'll give it one more shot.
Alright.
She's not paying attention.
I'm gonna book it.
I feel like that thing's coming after me.
I'm gonna chill out in here.
Wait for the danger to subside.
And I know when the danger has subsided because
the music...
right?
I hear breathing.
Should I check outside the barrel?
I'm gonna check outside the barrel.
Holy crap, he's right there!
OK, I'm glad I recorded for this part because
that is pretty creepy.
Can I listen in with my magic camera?
I feel like he's right outside the barrel
right now.
Oh yeah, OK he just went by.
Go go go!
Almost there.
I think.
Here's the thing!
Just gotta pull.
And here I go.
There's a well.
I wonder if there's a temple at the bottom
of the well.
Little Bongo Bongo.
Why did he just say Jessica?
What?
WHAT?!
I guess Bongo Bongo really is at the bottom
of the well.
We know that there's gonna be some kind of
rake looking thing that comes out of the vent.
Oh, that's my girl.
Alright.
Gotta go find her.
Oh, my camera battery is gonna die right now.
This is like the least rustic looking place
in the entire game.
See at this point I'm taking the scissors
for defense.
But as you saw at the beginning, my guy's
not a fighter.
Apparently that means he cannot defend himself
in any way, whatsoever.
I want to play a game.
Nah.
What's the deal with this TV?
Yeah, something just ate her out of the ceiling.
Trying to jump on that desk and figure out
what's going on.
But I can't.
Oh man.
That guy look friendly.
Oh my God, I'm actually fighting back a little
bit.
This is so nice.
Is he gonna come after me?
Oh crap!
I gotta book!
I gotta book!!
Some messed up stuff is going on.
Alright, well I think that gives you a pretty
good idea of this game so I'm gonna stop it
there.
I would like to go ahead and finish this game,
so maybe I'll post my updates on Outlast 2
on Twitter or something.
Alright so the next one is what is your favorite
horror game?
Honestly, Majora’s Mask, but I know people
are going to say that’s not a horror game.
To those people, I say:
But as more of a traditional horror game,
I’ve really been enjoying Duck Season, it's
a VR game, on the Oculus.
I talked a little bit about it on the last
Deadstream I think.
But it's super fun.
It’s a horror twist on the NES classic duck
hunt if that's not enough to sell you already,
the game is super unsettling.
I don’t want to get into spoilers or anything
so I’ll stop there.
But I will say there are a bunch of different
possible outcomes and just a lot of secrets
to uncover in it.
Really, really, enjoyed that one from Stress
Level Zero.
Alright, onto the next dare: I dare you to
play welcome to the game 2 on your channel.
Either videos or live.
I would love to see this.
What is it with you guys and the horror games
recently?
That’s three truths / dares in a row involving
horror games.
Which is funny because I've barely talked
about games on this channel.
Let me go see if I can download that.
OK, I do want to play that but I don't know
if that's gonna be physically possible right
now because I do not have room for it on my
PC and one of the rules was that I don't spend
a bunch of money and I would have to go out
and get a hard drive which would cost a bunch
of money, so I think I'm gonna have to skip
on that one for now.
Maybe I'll do a video on it in the future.
But I'll just tack another dare onto the end
of this video.
Truth: What is a movie that you are most looking
forward to?
Glass!
I know I already plugged M Night Shyamalan
once in this video but Glass is the sequel
to Split which came out a couple years ago
and I absolutely love that movie.
I've been waiting for a franchise like this
for like 20 years almost now.
I mean for me, seeing Split was one of the
best movie going experiences that I've ever
had.
Just the energy in the theater during the
last 2 minutes of that movie was amazing and
it's got me super pumped up for Glass which
comes out next year.
Dare: I dare you to cut your goatee.
Shoot.
I should have made a rule for this.
That should have been the fourth rule.
You can't tell me to cut my goatee.
But I didn't do.
Guess I've gotta follow through with it.
I mean, it is getting pretty long right now.
I guess it could use a trim.
It does say cut, it doesn't say shave off
entirely, so that's good.
But yeah, this is gonna be painful for me.
One day it will return.
There weren’t that many truths with a lot
of likes, clearly you guys came for the dares,
but here it is.
Truth: Would you ever have kids?
No, if there were babies crying everywhere
and stuff it would make it really hard for
me to record these videos for you guys.
Also this has nothing to do with this video,
but the comment below that says Slinderman
can kill Truth or Dear.
Which I just find so funny for some reason.
I think I’m gonna print that out and post
it on my wall.
OK so I have one more dare because I couldn't
quite do the Welcome to the Game one.
And the next one says: Dare: I dare you to
eat a whole raw onion.
Ohhh.
Uhm.
I don't have any onions right now so I'm gonna
have to go out and grab one.
That's gonna be tough.
"Fifty-one cents."
Have you ever eaten a raw onion before?
"No.
Are you going to?"
Yeah.
Apparently.
"Good luck!"
Thanks.
Not pleasant.
Not pleasant at all.
And that's just one bite.
Oh man.
I can already feel it.
This was the smallest one too.
There's no way I'm gonna make this.
Is it safe to eat a whole onion raw?
"Here's a summary from Fox News.
While raw onions contain a whopping load of
protective compounds, even cooked onions.."
Oh.
They say it's actually to stay healthy.
Sorry cat ears.
The actual taste of it is not that bad.
Just the burning sensation.
OK.
Tastes pretty bad.
The water helps.
I don't think he said anything about now being
allowed to have water.
Alright, big bite this time.
This is not fun.
Do not do this.
Do not try this at home.
I'm not even half way there.
It burns!
It just tastes like the spiciest thing ever
right now.
The first bite did not.
I can do this.
UH!
My tongue is burning right now.
Alright, I've been rolling this take for 10
minutes, I think I just need to take a break
and come back and finish the onion.
OK, sat down for 10 minutes.
Took a little break, did some editing.
I feel better now.
I think I'm ready to get back into it.
I think I can finish off like half of this
with the next bite and then hopefully after
that I can just down it and be done.
Instant regret.
It's gonna take at least two more bites.
Just imagine you're eating a burger and there's
onion on it.
A bit juicy quarter pounder with bacon.
Oh man, the burning is right back.
Taking the big bite: BAD IDEA.
Cause then it sits in your mouth and it's
burning.
How has YouTube changed your life?
Yeah, it made me eat a freaking raw onion.
For no reason.
I would gladly play 10 more hours of Outlast
2 if I didn't have to finish this onion.
Just a couple more bites...
Starting to get kind of a headache.
I think it's just from the stress, not so
much from the onion.
I made the mistake of taking a big bite again
and I was like no.
Actually the smaller bites might be the way
to go.
Then you can just down with water.
It's almost like taking a pill.
Yeah I think chewing it like released the
juices that make it burn.
Alright.
I'm gonna do this chunk.
And then I just have this left.
I couldn't do that chunk.
Couldn't do it.
OK, I don't know how close I have to get to
this thing, but I'm not gonna eat the bottom
thing.
I'm not gonna have onion on anything for a
long time after this.
UHH!!
Ok, I'm really close.
I just have this bit left.
It's the smallest portion that I've had so
far.
I mean it's like the smallest it's been.
Obviously.
I'm not even making sense.
It's really small now.
But it looks bigger than it was at the beginning,
you know?
My nose is like running too.
Alright.
Last piece of this.
One...
two...
Couldn't do it.
OK.
This is how much I have left.
I can do this.
I can finish this onion.
Last little bit.
Oh man!
That was going down and it did not continue
to go down.
That was going down and it came back up.
There's such a little amount left.
I'm gonna chew this.
And whatever happens happens.
*choking*
That last little bit just would not go down.
I still feel sick.
Do not try this.
This cannot be healthy.
I don't know what that articles was talking
about.
OK.
Alright.
I got a pack of gum.
I'm gonna eat all of it and then brush my
teeth for about 10 hours.
That's it.
Five truths.
Five dares.
Leave the worst dare you've ever had to do
down in the comments.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week.
Usually it's not gross out stuff like this.
I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.